we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here's a caller asking
why didn't I do heavy promotion of the
Lex Friedman interview that I did take a
listen David it's Alan from Jersey I'm
online and I see you did an interview
with Lex Friedman the world famous Lex
Friedman of the Lex Friedman podcast I
can't believe when did this happen how
did this happen where did this come from
David such a big you know
earth-shattering event of this you
should have been promoting this David
you should have told us you're
scheduling it and then after his
schedule he should have said this is
when it's gonna happen and then say this
and then say it just happened and then
say it just happened yesterday and then
say it happened two days ago then say
Lex Holman's gonna take three or four
more days before it's posted David why
didn't you give us every single update
of every single step in the process of
you doing Lex Freedom people would want
to know that type of information but
instead you gave us no warning okay so
here's the deal
many of you know that I hesitate to
pre-promote things especially things
Beyond My Control
because sadly they often get canceled or
postponed they never happen and then
people end up asking what happened and
in fact The Lex Friedman interview was
originally scheduled for a couple months
ago and I did pre-promote it on a couple
of live streams and then it did get
canceled at the very last minute and
then I had nothing I was there I was
sitting there holding my hat as people
say
um so this time around when it got
rescheduled I just didn't say a word
about it in case it got canceled again
and unfortunately this happens with
interviews we do on our show then they
get canceled perfect example is today's
Barbara Lee interview that we finally
did in aired today with you
it was postponed five times
and so imagine if I had promoted right
after the Adam Schiff interview hey and
tomorrow we've got Barbara Lee coming up
who's also running for that same Dianne
Feinstein senate seat and then I'm left
holding my hat and we have no interview
and then it's not clear what happened so
that's why I am now kind of cautious
about pre-promoting things that I don't
totally control
because they so often end up postponed
all right that's why but now the Lex
Friedman interview is out check it out I
posted it to my Twitter I posted it to
my blue Ski Blue Sky by the way are you
on Blue Sky please follow me on Blue Sky
I think it's actually a fantastic
platform it is invite only right now but
the invites are going out very strongly
follow me on Blue Sky
um it's on Lex's YouTube channel it's
everywhere we've got a great bonus show
for you today should the US get rid of
the debt ceiling is that a possible way
to get Beyond this periodic predictable
debt ceiling uh uh situation we can
discuss that on the bonus show what did
the California panel on reparations say
about what should be done with regard to
reparations we will discuss and lastly
the Biden Administration has some
interesting new plans for requiring
Airlines to pay stranded passengers
cover meals cover hotels in a much more
powerful way than is required right now
does this make sense is it over
regulation is it a nanny state or is it
just consumer protection all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
sign up at joinpakman.com if you don't
have the pleasure of the bonus show then
we'll see you back here tomorrow